そいやっ！
そ”い”や”ぁっ！！
机が凹んだ・・・・！？
こんにちは！ はじめしゃちょーです！
やっっとお待たせしましたぁ〜！　質問コーナーでぇ〜す！
はい！もう夏も終わるということでですねぇ
今回はなんとね！
約！９万件のコメント・質問を頂きました！
本当に！ありがとうございます！！
毎回言うんですけど、全てのコメントには
答えられないんですけども・・・
僕の方でなんとピックアップさせて頂いたコメントに答えていこうと思います。
良かったらお付き合いくださいませ・・・
・・・・では行こうっ★
おぅい！（怒）
帰れ！
帰れ（ry
帰（ry
何とか元気でございます！
ちょっとした気遣いのあるコメントで
僕は助かってます！
皆さんいつもありがとうございます・・・！！
採用されるんっすよぉ〜〜！！
コメントでね～、諦めてる人が多いぞ～！
質問コーナーは
"諦めたら負け"だ！
GOOD LUCK！👍
やだッ！
僕が大学１,2,３年生の時はですね・・・・
え〜と、コンビニのバイト
家庭教師。
TV局のアシスタントのバイト
屋台のバイト
あと、イベントのね。お手伝いとか、
短期でね、色んなバイトを派遣でやってました。
おいぃッ！！
よく見るぞ！
「なんなんですか」って言ったら採用されると思っている奴！！
今回は採用しない・・・・
なんなんなんうるせぇ〜！！
そうなんですよ！！
WA~WAWAWAWAWAWAWAWAWAWAwwwwwwww
WA〜〜〜〜〜wwwwwwwww！！！
UUu~~~~~wwwww
WAAAA〜〜〜〜〜wwwww！！！！！
PAAA~~~~~wwwwwww！！！！
(グサッ！！)
おわ~ん！！
ふぁむっ！
どうぅえぇーーーーーいッッッ！！！！
（ドン！！）
（！！！）(泣)
♫～
ごめん。
なめてんの？（怒）
俺のなかではいけると思ってるんだよ。
いただきます！
（咳き込み）
はじめしゃちょーの PhotoBookが出ます！
是非皆さん良かったら！　買ってみてね〜！
HAHAHAHAHAHAHAHA・・・・・。
憐れなものだなぁ・・・・。
能力を持たぬ人間という者の運命の定めとは・・・！
（チョキン★）
（ゲーム音声）
（おぉ・・・！）
（このザマだよ！！）
(3つのゲーム音)
あっ！クリアしたっ！！
あぁ〜あぁぁぁぁぁ〜〜〜っっ！！！
あぁぁあぁぁ〜〜〜痛でっ！！！！
おいッッ！！（怒）
ごおおおおおぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉぉおおおおおおおおおおおおrrrrrrrrrrrrrッッッ！！！
あぐうういいいいいぃぃぃぃぃぃぃぃあるぅ！！！
ガウゥッ！　ゴォォーーーーン！！！　ハフハフッ！！
ハフハフゥッ！！！
（はじめザウルスの咆哮）
（ごめんはじめ。途中で力尽きた・・・・。）
まじか・・・・。
髪の毛ロング～の・・・・
ビーサン（ビーチサンダル）の白いワンピース！
んで髪の毛はロングだね！
んでちょっとフリフリッとした白いワンピースですね！
理想のスタイルです！
「杖で四速歩行してみた」っていう動画があるんですけども・・・・。
それの最後にね・・・・・。
ケツの穴に本当に
杖が刺さちゃってメッチャ痛がってたんですけど・・・。
あれ実は、ケツが裂けちゃって・・・
血が止まんなくなって・・・・
気絶するくらい痛くて・・・・。
救急で病院に行きました。
かなり重症で
２、３日まともに動けなかったです・・・・。（汗）
はい。
お〜〜〜い。
（はじめしゃちょーによる翻訳）
はい。（諦めた）
（悲劇）ザラザラ~(白目)
ハイ、ビンタ！（パシィンッ！）
あっ・・・・・。入った・・・・。
（１０円玉が落ちる音）
（はじめしゃちょーの実況）
（勝利のゴング）
(決めポーズ)(パシィ！)
・・・・夏休みも残り少ないですけども。
皆さん、最後まで夏を楽しみましょうッ！！
じゃあなっ！（キラッ★）